welcome everyone Michael and Joey here
with the PC version of lawbreakers we're
going to give you a few general tips on
how well it can run on a modest system
and we're going to kind of tinker with
the quality settings and run 1080p and
4k and see what kind of frame rates we
can get so Joey how you feeling today
feeling good alright well I am too
really let's ready to break some laws
here we're going to break the law man
first we're going to hop into the
options menu and see what kind of video
settings we can actually take her with
so yeah we're looking at we got
resolution we can run in full we're
going to run the full screen here you
can do window to bordered windowed of
course you can also scale the screen if
you wanted to run a vendor at half
resolution but for now we're just going
to do AAB so we can do full scale all
right and so global quality settings is
gonna it's going to change everything so
you can have it's basically preset and
you got view distance how far you can
see anti-aliasing quality we're going to
leave that at high shadow quality
post-processing texture quality affects
quality all the basic stuff you would
see in a PC game now here is a little
different we can cap the framerate we're
not going to cap the framerate here
there's no need to but if you didn't
want it to go above 60 frames per second
on your particular monitor you could you
also set it with the slider there vsync
leave that off I always force it off in
my control panel settings so here we can
choose the anti-aliasing mode so they
only give us two options we get with it
we got FX a we get a temporal TT XA or
ta a fast approximate anti-aliasing if
you watched our video on the different
types of anti-aliasing you'll know what
that is it's more of a it's an easier
way to get anti-ghosting for your
hardware we're working with a very
modest system that's a little bit dated
I would say but it's still pretty
powerful we're running in AI 535 70 K
and we're also running a GTX 970 eight
gigs of ram on and we're using
neccessity working with the model with a
mid-range build is
kind of fun part when I say join yeah
all right so do you want to jump into a
real match here
oh yeah sure little try and my boy tell
us how good you are at this game - I
have never played it
all right I have I play I play a little
bit play a lot more over watch so this
is so this is kind of new thing for me
well I I picked Joey out of the office
too because one he's my boy and two he's
probably one of the better guys on
keyboard and mouse and a shooter yeah
I'd say that yeah so I would trust
myself but I got a I got a lay down the
knowledge for you guys or at least try
so yeah so right now we're trying to
jump into a match running for K the high
preset with no anti-aliasing so yeah
here we go we're an actual game we're
waiting absolute wearing players but
this is sort of a real-world world
situation where you know we have two
full teams shooting at each other flying
across the map and things have blown on
things people are shooting and there's a
lot of sex qualities going on you can
see how far the draw distance is in this
map when we go outside so right now
we're getting about high 40s - okay
we're going to get like mid 30s
- about to the 50s with 4k high here
with a GTX 970 so these are these frame
rates are I would say are actually like
fairly decent considering yeah okay yeah
yeah little oza little shaky here yeah
well yeah but it's all good so yeah
we're actually in a match yeah we're
getting about I would say an average of
40 dipping down to a mid mid 30s a
little bit and which is I would say it's
a little surprising considering how old
our PC is even though it's fairly decent
ooh Joey on the other hand is not decent
at this game so this is a good idea of
how well it's going to run on a mono
system do you want to go into the
settings menu and crank this up to take
a look let's see how much if we crank
the preset to ultra go to ultra and
check make sure that we for
anti-aliasing yeah okay we're good good
to jump back in
oh yeah so what we jump the old boy
there's kind of there's a big drop-off
in framerate we're getting mid to low
20s so I would not recommend running
this game in ultra 4k with the mid-range
video card I imagine that a 1070 wouldn
would fare a lot better a GTX 970 what
do you think says that he would fare a
lot better but I don't think you would
be hitting 60 of the desired 60 frames
per second for a competitive shooter so
leave that to the 1080p is maybe the RX
vega's when you get Y when you're able
to get your hands on that to run this
game 4k ultra so we're not going to be
very competitive here for you half the
frame range that we really are less than
half the frame rate that we really want
so yeah get good man trying okay so
that's kind of a general idea of how
well 4k is going to run you have to
ditch your teammates man because we're
going to switch it over to 1080p all
right sorry guys and yeah it's not going
to get the Rockets intermission great
now they can find a new teammate as you
fall to your death so we're gonna have
to exit out of the game and literally
change our desktop resolutions at 1080p
in order to get the game to run in 1080p
yeah we had a we had a lot of purple and
green yeah yeah while during testing
yeah we're switching resolutions and my
desktop was flipping out so for fraps it
says it's currently at 60 frames per
second right yeah I know
earlier like when you're testing it
bumped it all the way up to like 150 at
some points yeah would it would it do
that now since we're only in a min yeah
so well yeah the for lawbreakers when
you're in the menu for some reason it
caps out at 60 frames per second okay so
yeah if you go into the menu in game and
then you're messing around the settings
it's going to read 60 as soon as you get
out of the menus then the frame rates
going to jump back to whatever it's
supposed to be
and I'd say for 1080p ultra anti editing
on this is actually really good
so I mean lawbreakers is a competitive
shooter so they're not going to try and
push the graphical engine to its
absolute limit because we do or they
want this game to be more accessible for
PC users but to know that this game can
run fairly well
1080p maxed out with an older mid-range
build is pretty neat I'll get a man oh
snap guy right there that's you yes
we're getting pretty good performance
yeah yeah well we're getting about 120
when we get into smaller areas but let's
see if we can get up to 140 or Frasor
second which and the reason why we want
to do that is because there's a lot of
144 Hertz monitors out there so you can
actually get the maximum potential out
of your monitor if you have one of those
so if you want to hop into the graphics
menus and prairie leave your teammates
be per second it'll be okay yeah oh yeah
so if you're going to go to the preset
and just put it down too high we can
keep anti-aliasing on I think okay we
have temporal anti-aliasing on yeah
we're we're hitting up to 140 let's see
what it's like with a firefight you have
exhibited well I can find anyone here
haven't dipped below 100 quite yet oh we
hit the mid 90s whoo
other than the kind of technical
difficulties we had with changing the
resolution and you know having to run it
well just let you know also we're
running this in a borderless window
because we had a little trouble trying
to get this in like real fullscreen as
far as how much that'll affect
performance
I have Kimberly say but to know that you
know
you'll get really good frame rates out
of a fairly you know decent computer is
uh it's one less thing to you have to
hurdle over to you know if you want to
play a lawbreaker and you won't
necessarily have to worry about that
even if you don't have the best hardware
I obviously we didn't run any benchmarks
we didn't get any graphs or very
specific numbers for you but we did kind
of play around with some different
settings and put the game in a real
world real match situation so we can get
some general ideas of how what what kind
of frame rates we can get with
lawbreakers on PC and I would say it
runs pretty well I like it yeah looks
pretty good
and then once we turn like the greps
character fades up and like you know did
drop to maybe around 30 but it was
pretty good but I would say for me
personally since I like competitive
shooters a lot like having the frame
rate to be around like 140 or like just
anywhere above that 60 level is
absolutely satisfying
yeah so yes there you have it I hope you
found this video helpful so if you did
give it a thumbs up and keep your eye
out for our review on lawbreakers don't
forget to subscribe to GameSpot for more
game tech more tips more guides and all
that good stuff we'll see you later
thanks for watching